Now let's look at all the heavy lifting that needs to be done by runtime in
order to facilitate this map-produced style of programming.
The app developer writes his map function and reduce
function, and instantiates the programming library by calling
map produce. And the programming library splits the input
files that is provided by the user, that
is a key value space provided by the user,
into M splits. The number of splits of the input key value pairs,namely M,
can be automatic by the programming system. Or M can also be specified by
the user. In any case, once M is specified or automatically determined by the
programming framework, it splits the input key
value space into M splits. The next
thing that happens in the programming environment
is to spawn the master for this particular
map reduced computation, and all the worker
threads That are going to carry out the
work involved in map functions and reduce
functions. The master is special because the master
is the one that is sort of overseeing
the whole operation and keeping tab on which
workers are doing what functions, when are they
done,when to start new work, when to say
that the computation is done. All of those
chores are being orchestrated by this master. The next
thing that happens is that the master is
going to assign some number of worker threads
as the mapper worker threads and the number
of mapper working threads may correspond to the number
of splits that it has done in the beginning. So there are M splits, then M
worker threads are going to be assigned to mapping
function. So each worker thread is going to take
one portion of the input file split that
have been done, and apply the map function
on that particular input split. The next thing
that happens is that the master assigns reduce
tasks to some number of worker threads and the number of reducers to be
assigned to the workers, R, is something that is decided by the application.
Recall in the example that I gave you about looking for specific names. In
an input corpus, the number of unique names is something that
the app developer is specifying. That's where the
number R comes from. That's the number
of splits that the user is specifying, and
that parameter is going to be used by the
master to assign some number of workers as
reducers. The next thing that the master does. Is to plumb the mapper to the
reducers. Because now when the mappers produce that
output. That output has to be sent over
to the consumers of the intermediate results of
the mapper, namely the reducers. And setting up this
communication path between the producers of data The
mappers and the consumers of data that it uses
is the plumbing that the master does as the next thing. Now it's time to get to
work. The map phase, what it is going to
do is, it is going to read its respective split.
So each of these workers is assigned to the
mapping function. So each of the worker is working
on a particular split. And what they're going to do
is read from the local disc, the split that
they've been assigned, parse the input, and then call
the user defined map function. The user defined map
function is the one that is doing the core
of the work that needs to be done on the
input data set to produce the intermediate output.
The rest of it are things that needs to
be done in order to facilitate the work
to be carried out by the domain expert in
the map function. And the intermediate key value
pairs that we produced by the mapper will be
buffered in memory, so each one of these workers
Is doing a portion of processing the input key
value place and producing the respective
outputs. And periodically the intermediate results are
going to be written to files, which are on the local disks of the
worker or the respective workers. For this guy, on its local disk, its
going to write intermediate files corresponding to the
output of the map function. Similarly this
worker is going to write to its local disk, the intermediate files and so on.
And because the application developer has specified that there are R splits in
the reducers. Each worker, meaning each
map function that is associated with that
worker, is going to produce R intermediate file. One for each of the R workers
that are going to be doing the reduce operation.
And all these intermediate files are stored on
the local disk associated with each of these
computational nodes carrying out the worker function corresponding to
the map phase. And when they are done
with the map operation for the split that they
are handling, the worker will inform the master
that i'm done. And what the master's waiting on
is waiting on all of these mappers to get done before letting the workers to get
going on the input data set. So in this sense, the master is like the conductor
of an orchestra. He is started this mapping
function waiting for all of these guys to
get done, and when they indicate that they
have done the work by notifying the master.
And all of the M mappers that have
been assinged to these workers have completed that
work, then the masters say, okay now it is time to move on to the reduced phase.